huge news tonight from the house Intel
committee which voted this evening to
publicly release that bombshell we hope
it's a bombshell FBI a FISA memo I
should say
alleging serious surveillance abuses by
top officials at DOJ and the FBI now
President Trump has five days to decide
whether he has any objections to
releasing this classified memo Adam
Schiff the top ranking Democrat on the
committee is wasting no time expressing
his outrage today this committee voted
to put the president's personal interest
perhaps their own political interest
above the national interest
we also learned tonight that the Intel
committee has opened an investigation
into the DOJ and the FBI and joining us
now to discuss these developments
congressman Chris Stewart a member of
the Intel committee from Utah
congressman great to see you when
couldn't expect this memo to be released
well I would love it released tonight I
think that's in your pocket get it I
want that memo pull it out come on let's
go hopefully soon I mean it's important
for the American people to see this and
I don't think the president will delay I
hope he doesn't this is what Mark Walker
your colleague a Republican from North
Carolina said earlier today let's watch
if your audience or if somebody's
believing that this is the end all
smoking gun
it isn't yeah does it name names does it
present some very intriguing facts as as
I would share that that that makes you
ask even more questions to make the case
that this is the most shocking document
the history of mankind
I believe that's a little hyperbole are
you guys engaged in hyperbole Congress
well I can tell you I have a bin now
some people have and we've actually
cautioned against that but this is an
important document it's very important
for the American people know that and I
think there's two things worth saying
here one is the process I mean I listen
to mr. Schiff and my head just wants to
explode I mean look these are my Air
Force wings my father was Air Force
pilot I mean to accuse us of saying we
would endanger national security is just
silliness this memo doesn't do that but
what it does do is it asks these
questions was the FBI fair were they
accurate we've been making accusations
against people serious accusations so
they've been called trade
they've been called treasonous for more
than a year now did the FBI make those
kinds of accusations against innocent
people with laughable evidence that's
the kind of things this man will alone
congressman gates from Florida has been
on our air been a frequent guest on this
show and I mean to listen at congressman
gates this has just got barnburner of a
memo and I think people have gotten
their hopes up that you know there's
this guy is gonna go and then this
person is gonna lose his job and maybe
this one's gonna go to jail and I always
find that Republicans tended sorry be
bad storytellers and I'm worried about
that as as our other congressmen to whom
I've spoken in the last 48 hours well
we've tried to get some people to kind
of temper their language but but you
know and I can't speak for what everyone
has said but this memo is very factual
it's not emotional it doesn't draw any
conclusions it just lays out the facts
and lets you draw goals all right Nancy
Pelosi spoke about an hour ago
and I know you haven't seen it so this
is a gift for you let's watch they have
made up a memo that isn't even true and
they're lying to the American so what
are you gonna do about it
the Republican Party has as I said
crossed over to cover up their deadly
afraid of the Russian investigation ray
got gay the director of the FBI
obviously recently selected by President
Trump he got the memo
he could have come out and said this is
reckless don't release it with all due
respect you really don't know what
you're talking about right now
Wow she even gave it to Chris Cuomo that
was pretty good right up on the roof
here I would like to know I would like
to know if she's been on reading them
well we have members and she read it I
don't know I can tell you there's a
Lance story yeah we know and there's
been a Bobby cowasaurus I want to know
but we had members of apartment justice
over the weekend who are saying it was
reckless to release his memo when they
had not read it they didn't know what
was in it they were making accusations
that they had no knowledge of and I
think about sessions and all this Jeff
Sessions what is he said I mean he's a
head of the Justice Department yeah in
which the FBI resides so is he or he
just not gonna come to this Russia I've
recused myself from all things related
to Russia which I still don't understand
well and and that's one of the great
disciplines I think Jeff Sessions was
one of most decent honorable men in
Washington DC but shouldn't put rod
Rosen
huge missiles deputy but I would say but
he's recused himself from one of the
most important house hearings that were
in camera case yourself they're gonna be
attorney John and I and I've said to him
sir I wish you would not have done that
but because you have I think you have an
obligation to step aside and let a
department be led by someone who will
not step you're saying sessions can't
can't lead this department on this I've
said that I've said in the past it's
just unfair for him it's unfair to what
we are trying to accomplish are there
are other people who agree with you more
than the few that we've seen quoted
publicly I think I think there's some I
love Jeff Sessions first of all I think
he would have been a great DHS secretary
for some reason this fit I'm concerned
about it's great on immigration so good
on some of the enforcement gang stuff
he's great on the frankly the marijuana
enforcement which i think is good to
give discretion in the field offices but
this investigation I'm sorry was a fraud
from the beginning should never have
been undertaken rod Rosenstein like wet
himself when he went over to the hill if
he's worried about answering questions
he's like I'm gonna board a Special
Counsel I'm sorry but that just doesn't
inspire a lot of confidence and so I
agree I and I agree he's one of the most
decent man look these accusations that
he was deceptive in his testimony that's
just nuts and now who watches that house
he was answering the question as he
understood it but unfortunately the city
choose up good people sometimes that's
why you can't be recusing yourself a
name and rod Rosenstein as your deputy
Thank You congressman we look forward to
the release and if you can give it to me
before the end of the hour I'd
appreciate it